[Music]
in this clip vox isn't happy that his
chat room is being taken over by gamma
trolls i don't know if you know this
he's not he's not happy about it and i i
i have to say this well you could play
it now
so we're still waiting
um
let me make a couple of announcements
here before we dive into it
um we had a discussion on the chat who's
we and
this week
it was very clear that
um
most people would like me to
uh
shut down the chat
or
um
severely restrict it somehow so that's a
lie i know you i already pointed this
out last night so vox
is explaining this in a
he's insane
basically what vox is saying is that
you folks you guys the ones who talk in
the chat room
uh voted on it and decided that you
are allowed way too much freedom to talk
so you decided that you need to shut up
so you're going to be shutting your chat
down that's what he just did each
it's so [ __ ] it's such [ __ ] it's
hilarious teddy spaghetti is ready
spaghetti yeah teddy spaghetti i love it
by the way it's the most demeaning it is
dismissive thing you can call him
everyone call him teddy spaghetti teddy
spaghetti i want teddy's i want the word
spaghetti
uh to be a band term in his chat room by
next teddy spaghetti
most people
feel and i tend to agree
that
as the popularity that of the stream has
increased
the
quality of the chat has gone down
considerably
and it's gotten distracting to the point
that
um
you know it's really gotten distracting
to the point that i'm distracted it's
only distracted because you rely on it
see that's the thing with these guys
it's
look
he has more subs in us but 10 000 more
than us but we have about the same live
viewers as he does give or take give or
take right
yeah uh
but but he
he's the one that relies on the chat so
the reason he's not gonna ever delete
the chat completely is he doesn't know
how to do a one-hour show without
something to interact with yeah he's not
capable of doing it none of these people
are they just don't know how to do it
they don't know how to do it uh he can't
do it and uh that that's why that's why
now he's doing the was it five minutes
slow mode and i don't even [ __ ] on p
look there's a gajillion people on the
planet that can't do it and i don't and
i don't fault you for not being able to
do it it's not easy
but many people just don't do it these
guys think they deserve money for how
great their [ __ ] is and you can't even
do it no exactly
and people are enjoying the streams left
so
um maybe it's because you're boring so
for now i'm exp i'm
experimenting ready um
what i've done is i've slowed down
the speed at which people can post chats
fair enough we do that yeah we do that
just to chat what about 40 seconds for
45 seconds maybe even a minute 30
seconds minute tops right once every
five minutes
[Laughter]
five minutes see the problem is vox let
me help you out here
can i i'm gonna help him out
the problem is vox when you do it once
every five minutes when someone does say
something shitty it's going to stay
there a lot longer before other people
post
to delete it and the other thing vox let
me help you out here too
when people want to [ __ ] with you do you
think they only have one channel do you
think they only have one account rugs is
that what you think
box
we have some followers on here that have
20
25 channels each yeah
it's ridiculous
so
all you're gonna do now you're gonna
really drown out the people that
actually want to be there it's this is
great because this is again this is
classic internet the more you react the
more it's of course attract more
vultures and it's of course we're gonna
get all the credit and the blame for
these are all from them but now you're
just going to attract other ants yep
and so
so that's interesting
i don't believe there's a possibility
that someone knows my ip address and i'm
being doxxed
we've looked into it it looks actually
like it might be
a browser-based attack
nobody's doxing him nobody's attacking
him none of that's happened by the way
that's a lie we're literally box that
he's [ __ ] lying they always cry they
always cry this but you're lying vox
let's do this let's let let me let me
put my hand down and i'm going to put it
i'm going to raise my hand i'm going to
swear
on all this holy vox
i have my i have bible installed in this
laptop so it's like putting my hand on
the bible
i plead guilty
i plead guilty to one sin and one sin
only and that is ridiculing you
endlessly
and that will never look at me
that will never end fox but we don't dox
poo we don't we're just not that's like
sadistic no we wouldn't do that it's so
much funnier to just ridicule you
um we looked into it too who's the wii
who's the wii
so we'll have to look into that we who's
we
one thing they've noticed is a few years
i think maybe it's remember the show
herman's head yes i think there's just a
bunch of characters in box day's brain
yep it's a great show by the way it's
very underrated underrated it's a
different
uh browser it might help like firefox
appears to be the worst
uh so if you stay away from is he
talking about unauthorized
no the website's not being doxxed it's
it's overloaded because you didn't buy
the correct pack it's like i know that
doesn't work you didn't buy the correct
hosting package so every time you put up
a barcelona boom or a [ __ ] 10
gigabyte barcelona boomer episode that's
it you're weighing down your server
because if you don't buy enough server
they allocate
also are you on your own server or are
you sharing a server with other people
because you have to pay extra money i
know because we have to do you have to
pay extra money to be on your own server
or at least a server only shared by a
couple people this is why we got annoyed
when everybody kept saying post your own
video
we kept telling people over and over
again that's a very simple instinct to
have
there's a reason why we don't do it
there's a reason why jesse from pod
awful doesn't do there's a reason why so
many people don't host their own video
it would be nigh impossible
to provide good quality the way youtube
does youtube has
the
has the [ __ ]
software and they have all of this
proprietary
code they figured out streaming a long
time ago there's just no way to do it so
he thinks he's just so you should slap
him like the way i would slap images up
on our website and host them right just
slapping them in and uploading them and
going
there it is that's i can't that's why we
were just getting the
the jump yeah oh
um
firefox
and chrome that might help so it's not
our website oh let me do it as fox
see what you have to understand is
is that it's not unauthorized tv
that sucks
it's your choice of browser
it's because you're using
shitty
um uh browsers that nobody uses like
firefox
like
everyone you know people use viral do
you know what happened if [ __ ]
if somebody said to like royce hey uh
your website doesn't work on firefox
royce or i would somebody would go
somebody [ __ ] fix this now of course
you can't work on firefox a lot of
people use firefox make it work on all
the normal things
and yes uh i am aware that the trolls
are coming from uh an anti-owen group
that's fine the own resistance group no
no no they're not coming from an
anti-own group vox they're coming from a
you are a boring dork who is trying to
manipulate crazy owen rock's this isn't
an anti-owen group we are revenge of the
sis uh we have been around for going on
two years now uh we have a pretty good
following uh we do many many things
besides picking on owen or picking on
you or picking on that
frog um
i know you i know you're
you're i know what you're trying to do
but you're doing
this
strategy out of like a very old playbook
you're trying to reduce your enemies to
like one simple they're all gammas
they're all these anti yeah of course
yeah they all have a jet like you're
doing this there's never any
self-reflection i was trying to say this
last night and and i and i gave a very
heartfelt appeal to vox day and i was
like look fox for your own good you got
to stop this [ __ ] you're not as smart as
you think you are
you you even if you are smart as you
think you are even if owen has 147 iq
even if me and royce are the two
smartest men who ever lived
you will never be as smart
as the internet collectively is yes you
know what i mean like the internet has
an iq of 20 000 because it's a bunch of
people going you missed that
no no he said this earlier oh [ __ ] i
even catch that right dude did you see
on look slow it down on this frame
there's a bunch of autistic people you
think anybody on 4chan or pole or a
bunch of geniuses
no it's large crowdsourcing projects of
people going you read pages 80 through
160. i'm going to read pages 1 through
80. we'll just it's people working again
you're never going to be smarter than
all of that so stop fighting it
um
but we're going to take care of it you
know how it's not a it's not an uh an
issue
the moment you shut off because he might
go members only but the moment he shuts
off his chat because that's the next
step if he shuts off his chat his
viewership is going to drop
dramatically
people want to be able to talk and
communicate even if the host isn't
reading every chat with each other
that's a big part of youtube streaming
it just is the chat is a big part of it
unless you're a joe rogan who can turn
your chat off
you're not joe rogan you need that you
know and when you don't have a chat on
here's the other reason why you won't
turn the chat off because if you turn
the chat off you can't send super chats
and as we're going to find out here in a
second as we're going to find out here
in a second a big part of the business
plan for unauthorized tv well i don't
let him tell us so he's going to do what
i said which is he's going to end up
gold members only which is going to be
hilarious the first live stream
on unauthorized tonight the good news is
that it's possible
to
dual stream
on unauthorized and on
youtube so we can
we can keep the super chats
on youtube and there's even a uh
so your business plan because you're not
giving exclusive content for an
authorized tv
your business or your wife's business
plan as we find out she's the one that
wears the pants your wife's business
plan
is you you your show now relies on
the super chats and the whole reason
unauthorized was created was how much
youtube was [ __ ] creators and by the
way
daddy owen doesn't get super chats
anymore but vox daddy needs it like vox
needs his old teddy spaghetti old teddy
spaghetti needs his super chats yeah i
was pointing this out last night too
it's so amazing that you're gonna go
sign up over here for this exclusive
members only website that also has no
exclusivity or you could just still just
watch me on youtube because i'm still
gonna be over here because i need them
super chats like it's just so [ __ ]
disingenuous
this
uh super chat alert
although i don't understand widget will
automatically connect when you start
streaming to youtube
right click to manual select live event
or edit what what widgets is he talking
about what is this about and why this uh
well
let me know if that um
imagine watching this and going i'm
gonna give this man fifteen hundred
dollars of my hard-earned money it's a
good investment well hang on widget will
automatically connect when you start
straight let us you know once he gets
the widgets up and running royce okay
once he figures out widgets we're done
for
let me know if you're seeing widget
jihad
widget jihad that widget will
automatically connect thing i don't know
why showing up but because maybe you
didn't have a good business plan or a
good idea you threw something together
without putting any work into it and
figured out how to do this correctly you
probably got one of your fans who kind
of dabbles a little bit in website stuff
and he [ __ ] helped you out a little
bit but you don't know what you're doing
can i can i give him a little mel gibson
thing sure on the day of the youtube
streaming the widgets will automatically
connect
it's uh
anyhow we'll figure it out we'll figure
it out [ __ ] it keep giving me money
though well i figured it out but i'm
figuring [ __ ] out guys give me money
it's it's this weird entitlement like
again royce and i had to come here and
show up every day for a year before
anybody gave us money yeah we had 30
dollar patreon account and no super
chats and no stream labs for over a year
yeah okay
and we showed up every day and we
delivered a product
with the faith that hopefully someday it
would pay off
we have very rarely had to tell this
audience
sorry guys we'll figure this [ __ ] out
and when we have it's always been his
computer completely exploded into a ball
of flame or the internet is literally we
don't have a choice right everyone's
internet is down in this neighborhood
but there's never been a
oh yeah the website's down well it'll be
down for a month while we figure it out
oh we're going to do a show well like
you understand if his computer blew up
like we'd have to
like spend a lot of money getting one
fast shipped here that's already built
and ready to like there's no time yeah
this is just yes it's uh 200 for the
year
yeah i'm figuring it out whatever well
whatever man do you imagine working at a
company like this
where they're telling you to go out and
get subscriptions but they're like well
we're working on all these other things
no i don't want to work for compound i
can't
i can't go out here you know what the
you know watch the new lenny dykstra
show
lenny daxter doesn't want to watch the
new lenny dykstra show
and uh
roy bear doesn't seem to understand
we're not having a conversation roy bear
it gets good
that that's the whole point
and
i don't want to have a conversation with
you
losers
can i give a big shout out to missy link
because he goes through these episodes
and gets me time stamped so i want to
thank him because he does god's work i
don't know how he does it but he's also
the one that's been in there every day
oh yeah and what about the subscription
fees yeah what about the subscription
fees
everybody's oh
[Laughter]
i want people to be able to ask
questions he's you know what his missing
link is uh is frank reynolds showing up
to that strike
remember i don't know nothing about this
fancy college guy in his fancy words he
starts getting everybody to start riding
during his strike
roy bear doesn't seem to understand what
this is important we're not having a
conversation roy bear
that that's the whole point
and
i don't want to have a conversation with
individuals
the arrogance of this man by the way he
had to he noticed he paused
because individuals
was not the first thing i said he wanted
you people yeah was what popped in his
head yeah
you [ __ ] pay pig losers i do not want
to have a conversation with you
i want people to be able to ask
questions and i want to be able to
address them i do not want to hear
follow-on questions
i do not want to hear subsequent things
i mean for example in the
in email
one certain way to make sure that you
never get a response from me again
is
i get these emails from people saying oh
i understand you're very busy and this
and the other thing but he's not by the
way he's not very busy
he's not very busy important question
okay fine
if i have the time i'll answer it
and it's always a huge mistake when they
respond with
oh he responded to me i'll ask more
questions
what a [ __ ] no you won't
at least you won't get any answers this
guy thinks he's calm
this guy thinks he's too cool hey hey
fox hey hey fox bud you have 28 000
subscribers yeah that's more than us
probably it's double us actually and
that's fine
get it although which is weird that our
live viewers are more about the same as
yours that's very odd to me but whatever
that's fine
you have 28 000 subscribers okay you
don't have enough
you don't have enough to
[ __ ] you your fans like you don't like
mr i want to help people when they email
you know how many emails mike and i are
direct messages we try we really do try
to reply to them and yeah and i look i
do my best i'm not great at getting back
to everybody i will admit that i'm
almost as bad as vox sometimes at
getting back to people
but
i try to
and i also don't have the utter disdain
for the entire audience of this guy like
ugh another one of these [ __ ] like if i
don't get back like i get depressed
sometimes sometimes i'm just locked and
it's not you like ask my family and ask
women who date me how doting i am and
all the time just not
so it's not like so i get that but i try
to explain to people like hey that's me
that's how i've always been i was raised
by a mother who just was an ice-cold
irish lady
so i just i'm used to having my space
because my mom wanted her space so like
but i've never been like i'm not here
to have a conversation with you [ __ ]
plebiscus
it's it's like you just go
all right look man guys i'm busy i'm
trying it back to everybody i i
understand
that i suck at this and i do my best
like he's just
[ __ ] conversation with you
so anyhow it's it's uh
it's just
amusing how um
how
a lot of
subscribers
a lot of
um youtube subscribers messages a lot of
you know people who are just
tuning in
seem to be under the mistaken impression
that i answer to them in any way shape
or form
who talks like this to their audience no
no and don't get me wrong we don't
answer to anybody either we work for
ourselves we work very hard to get to a
point in our lives where we work for
ourselves we don't technically answer to
anybody but vox if in your mind you
truly think
that you don't answer to them
on some level
then this is a disaster this business
you're trying to build is a [ __ ]
disaster you're telling people to give
you money for a service that isn't done
yet and also in the same breath telling
them that they don't matter and you
don't answer to them
that's a bold strategy cotton let's see
if it pays off for him
i don't
you know
i don't need to do this
i started doing this because
my readers asked me to
no no you you
let me guess your blog spot readers
asked you to no no no no no you needed
some dough homeboy because your teddy
spaghetti games didn't do as good as you
thought and your mortal kombat
soundtrack dried up after the 90s
evil behaviors that's bad
um
otherwise i don't i don't think it's uh
necessarily an issue
virgil hiltz says you being distracted
is my only concern well i think we
avoided it tonight i think it'll be fine
um
justin carpenter said i lost a lot of
respect for you when you peddled a
subpar product so owen can get to
freeload as a wannabe farmer
[Laughter]
wow
who the [ __ ] wrote that ow
that's a biting comment that hurts
that hurts arm for a living he's a joke
also can pause i'm sorry but at least so
lisa mason in the chat had a good one
too uh we need to start referring to it
as the dork stream it is yeah the dork
stream pork stream hosted by teddy
spaghetti
that's gonna really bother him yeah you
know he watches these right
hey i know hey by the way teddy
spaghetti you realize i said this on
night wave last night you were born to
be stuffed into lockers like there's no
better job in life for you
like whether it's physically or just
virtually in this new youtube world you
are a locker dweller
i'm going to lose your ability to
comment on this channel oh no he'll use
his other 15 you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
nerd oh no he's getting the direct
desired outcome of what he just did oh
no
thanks
and you read it
you're a [ __ ] i understand that that's
like a career criminal like hell's
angels like walking up and punching a
cop in the face and the cops going
you're going to jail now buddy for at
least 10 years and he's gonna go yeah i
know i got off my motorcycle and said
i'm gonna punch that cop in his face
like i knew doing this wow was gonna end
now his wife also has been organized
going through his super chat so he could
read him at the end that way he doesn't
get uh well that's what i was saying
last night yeah i pointed that out
because i
he didn't say that i said that that's
probably what's happening because he
said i'll read them at the end and i was
the one that said so your wife who
whispered to you off camera is now
writing them all down and bringing you
the good ones what a [ __ ]
class act as foxes
because i don't want you as a
i don't want you as a subscriber i don't
want you as a viewer
um
[ __ ] gammas
the unauthorized is not a subpar product
yes it is and it's a non-existent
product actually it's not the right
thing you're right it is actually not a
subpar product because the subpar
product would be still a product
owen is not
freeloading nor is he a wannabe farmer
yes he is have you seen his farm
[Laughter]
you're a liar
i don't believe you no fox
you're the liar
i don't care whether you respect me or
not because i don't want anything to do
with life
so you are you so did your little five
hey did your little five-minute chat
experiment work
did it work i don't think it's working
because apparently it looks like he's
still getting mean super chats the
problem is is that if it was yeah do you
understand that people will pay for the
luxury
of making fun of you you get that vox
can i say this alexander in the chat
puts it the best owen is a [ __ ]
gardener he does not farm god damn it's
annoying that would be and by the way
gardening means also farming a little
bit like if you do
a little garden of tomatoes and some
cucumber that's gardening that's okay
cool you're growing some vegetables but
that's not farming he went and bought
goats
from a store
which i'm sure his wife loved
man bear pig says any thoughts regarding
roosh v his streams are awesome and he
seems to be aligned with you and all
that [ __ ] scam artist yeah uh
roosh v by the way is just a guy who
watched a lot of black phillip
and uh
made all of patrice o'neill's points
autistic and
sells them to incels to
okay like he's a pickup artist but like
all these pickup artists and you know
return of kings all these websites
patrice o'neill was like the jesus
christ figure in that story he came to
earth he gave all that [ __ ] to you for
free and it's out there and then he died
and i'm like i'm assuming him too and uh
well some people say it was bill burr
but i don't know
processed foods i mean technically it's
so um
patrice died he left behind all this
great knowledge and now there's all
these scummy prosperity preachers that
take his gospel
and they go like i'll show you how to
pick up chicks and people go wow some of
that stuff does work yeah give me money
patrice never wanted your money he just
did a show where he wanted to show you
guys
how to tell people like how to assert
yourself and get what you want out of
life
this is part this part's great here
it's teddy spaghetti i find it amusing
that that people
are actually trying
to
some some of these idiot gammas are
actually trying to troll me
about it's my games
and it works because you're talking
about it teddy spaghetti yeah teddy
spaghetti teddy spaghetti it's never
gonna go away now
my best-selling game did 6 million units
what's your best self just keep that in
mind what is it he won't say that's the
thing he always talks about these other
games that he was in well what's the
best-selling game you did what was it so
we could look it up
you know
i've talked to
and actually from what i've heard it's
actually four hundred thousand it's not
six million yeah so and some some
estimates go as low as 250. yeah
some of the top game developers six
million really is the go-to number to
just it's it's almost become a joke at
this point at every time somebody says 6
million you're like so it's a made-up
number
6 million has become the new 1 million
because i guess for inflation
top game designers
and they've
asked me to work with them why don't you
so
given
some of the
uh
industry people that have totally shown
me
an amount of respect nobody the last
game you made came out 15 years ago
so what respect are we talking about
you're a [ __ ] nobody you're a loser
nobody cares about you the thing is
teddy spaghetti has tried everything
he's tried being a music guy he's tried
being a game designer he's tried been a
philosopher he's trying to be a blogger
he's tried being a turtle nothing seems
to work for him and i love that guys
like this too they'll always break about
all of the things they've done and
failed at like
oh well i was like i was a music artist
i did game design i'm an author okay so
you did a bunch of things poorly you
can't do all once in a while a leonardo
da vinci is born who's just so goddamn
gifted that he can do you know what i
remember that like he was painting
chapels and sculpting and he's signing
helicopters he could draw a perfect
circle by hand
but he was like he had like these weird
like he was such a genius that he was
like someday we'll have helicopters and
medicine it would be [ __ ] crazy also
i paint and sculpt and he did all of it
well but like most people that do all of
those things do it poorly right and many
many people are just good at doing like
one
awesome thing like i'm sure that macho
man randy savage uh if he got into
sculpting and painting and making music
well he did do music but if he got into
all this other [ __ ] he would have been
like
he would have never been good at being
macho man macho man needed to just be a
wrestler for 20 and be macho man like
you can't just keep failing at [ __ ]
teddy and bragging about it
why would you think i give the even a
quantum of a dam
about anything that you would think on
the matter because you're bringing it up
and talking about it
because if you didn't care what people
think you wouldn't be bragging if you
didn't care what people think you
wouldn't be bragging that six million
people bought your game either you're a
phony teddy you're a phony teddy
spaghetti and you're riding on the back
of [ __ ] big bear like he's
in the [ __ ] mad max movie you know
what i mean and he's a little [ __ ] on
his back that's what you're doing you're
using him and you're gonna have a
falling out with him too and when that
happens your subs are gonna [ __ ]
plateau and no one's gonna care about
you anymore yep that's what's gonna
happen well they've already plateaued
now that now our goal is to get them to
drop